het is maandag
tijd voor training
na het slechte weer van de afgelopen week
waardoor we geen oefenwedstrijden hebben kunnen doen
is het tijd voor de eerste training
voor de eerste officiële competitiewedstrijd
zijn de boys klaar voor
zijn wij er klaar voor natuurlijk
maar eerst voor bespreking
luister we hebben vorige week helaas
geen wedstrijd gehad
geen wedstrijd
maar de 2 allebei zijn niet door gegaan
niet getreurd
de eerste conditiewedstrijd begint deze week
mooi weer we gaan sowieso beginnen
ik GA eerst 1 kleine voorbespreking doen
wat ik hierin GA bespreken
omdat ik vooral te maken met het feit dat ik eigenlijk
vandaag 1 selectie bekend Wil maken
maar dat GA ik vandaag niet doen
ik HEB 1 week minder gehad
om te laten zien wat je kan doen
dus ik geef je nog 1 week
om te laten zien wat je wel kan doen
maar zaterdag
de bespreking is geweest
we gaan nu het veld op
de jongens zijn bezig met de warming up
we gaan daarna met tikoefening verder
en dan 1 partijtje
vandaag 1 zeer relaxte training voor 1 hele grote groep
we zijn namelijk met 22 man
zoals jullie kunnen zien is de grote groep
allemaal warm aan het worden
terugweg 2 stop
de jongens doen nu 1 casa loopoefening
en ze schreeuwde Bob
eyseboe ijzere
bal maar naar binnen
ja
ja ja
hey ossi jammer
dankjewel voor de nieuwe jongens
goed gewerkt want al die jongens ook
goed gewerkt iedereen heeft goed zijn best gedaan
is 1 goede training
uh de trein aangeven
ja je staat alleen al voor de post verliezen 3 2
1 0 HEB je die niet gezien
en daarna zaterdag wedstrijd selectie
woensdagavond nog bekend gemaakt
nog bekend gemaakt
iedereen die zich eerste week bij coaston
bezig met de wedstrijd
volgende week maandag wordt de rest bekend gemaakt
dankjewel jongens het is 4 woensdag